hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bad dream coma now
we're going into the park which ah I had
an I had an assumption about that it
might be the park that is closed off
over here be happy
think about nice things no I'm not gonna
do that I'm gonna think about all the
nightmares that keep me awake at night
considering that I may not be awake at
night considering this is all a
nightmare that is cohesive and
destructive anyway time to go into the
park think about nice things ah damn
those flowers alright fine hi you don't
look so good both of you I mean you look
fine old man but I don't like what
you're doing with your arm there I like
what you're doing with your arms there
because the alternative is just awful if
you want to make yourself useful find
the nurse okay alright mr. Bossypants
[ __ ] you with your hidden hair and shirt
alright hello can I go in there can I go
in there I want to go in there real bad
Derek whoa hello I can put that on the
computer computers in there alright
squad along I'm in what are you doing
what you just told me are you blind or
stupid don't you see the line you're not
the only one who needs help wait
patiently for your turn excuse me you
[ __ ] I can understand that guy over
there but he seems a little preoccupied
Tommy to talk to you you fine oh hi
hello hi hello nurse how you doing I
won't tell you to shut up immediately
but let's hear you out hey can you help
me I need to pay for a bus ticket but
don't have any money Oh
maybe you can have some spare change all
right sure nurse there's a lot of people
to need your help over there you know
someone holding in his intestines in
this weird world where everyone can get
hurt but not die all right so I don't
know where I'm gonna find any spare
change but I'm gonna go looking I guess
in the weird horrible Park
anybody got a spare change huh
ding dong plink plonk this is no way I'm
gonna find it around here didn't I get a
coin didn't I trade I thought I traded
that bird for a sweet coin didn't I oh
wait
something over there what do we got are
we looking for can I burn you what am I
looking at
whoa hi thank you okay carry on
thank you for being my friend will a
shiny nickel help you
it's a photo the five is backwards you
can't pay with that ooh I did not know
that I didn't
I forgot entirely that I could magnify
things okay so does anybody wanna shiny
coin can I pay you shiny coin for your
spot in line sir no yes maybe so
all right fine then no hi all right
okay sit kid thanks thanks for laughing
thanks for cheering me up
you sure do think nice thoughts little
kid right I'm gonna go in here now the
eyeball tree oh it's the tree of balls
of that our eyes oh okay well I'm gonna
around here
Oh God me you lose empty bottle good
enough I suppose you want a head you
want me to light you on fire
you want a floopy disc you want a coin
you want a bottle of booze what do you
want what do you want you I bastards ah
all right fine then I'm assuming that's
all I needed for me oh so I'm gonna get
out of here with that shitty kid coming
back and laughs at me but I think it's
gonna be good enough unless there's
something in the distance again there's
probably a lot of tiny secrets in this
game that you could easily overlook that
don't need you to actually complete the
rest of the game you want some booze I
didn't ask for that
how about floopy discs how about I heard
you want a head a head of a teddy bear
his body lies in the hospital yeah I
know I'm aware of that
gloves fire don't need matches now they
got no use for it
okay yeah I got no use to help you put
here I go anybody want some booze hey
you want some booze we got booze I got
some booze for you oh I got a bottle of
boys that poison one of you which one
are you can I poison the nurse can i
poison the nurse right about this tree
sploosh that feels bad but apparently
it's fine the eyes don't need to be
there thank this creeper maybe I can use
it on the manhole cover yep okay into
the bowl I don't like this
where am I know is that Gor is that
blood I can't believe I have to ask that
question but if that goo or is that
blood
Oh coin that looks like a fake coin
again why do I have somebody got in fake
coins good is that gonna do anybody oh
hi there you are hello all right I've
been looking all over for you
I had to check something out I need you
here
many patients in the hospital are
waiting for your help the doctor is not
helping at all I know that's why I
wanted to find his body I can't handle
it myself any longer
there's too many patients too much
suffering someone needs to help me I'll
look you should go back to the hospital
okay hey can you pay for my ticket
please I have no money with me yes I can
just go I don't have Thanks
I was trying to help too I'm cool
sweet come on give me a chance I know I
hate oh shut up allowed me now come on
you're back yeah I'm back do you have
any news I have had an eraser and I
erased someone from existence so you
want to tell me the death has stopped
doing performing her duties that makes
sense your sentence didn't at least in
this place we should find her as quickly
as we can maybe we'll convince her to
help us get out of here maybe it's us
maybe the nurse is death maybe that's
how that makes sense I see you have the
teddy bears head try maybe to fix him
his body is in room number 15 he spent a
lot of time at the graveyard and they
have some important information for us
he's an imaginary creature but who knows
I need to do something we'll see how you
deal with your matters good luck I know
where his head it was body
no wait his body I was thinking that the
teddy bear maybe had his body but I
don't think that's a hundred percent
accurate here and moreover to the entire
story of whatever's going on here like
there's a lot of unanswered questions
but it's starting to be slowly pieced
together like this world in the way that
it exists like it this world does
obviously exist but there's more to it
than that like it's not just a coma
state where everything is fake because
that wouldn't make any sense there's
some reality to this I mean maybe it is
just made up in everybody's mind but
everybody's in the same place together
you have to remember that fact people
are here together in a same place so
whatever that means you know we'll find
out soon enough but until then hello
okay alright then goodbye weird
why can't I get in here no that was a
lot darker than I thought it'd be
oh that's dark okay hello how's those
spiders hey may I ask you another favor
nothing but favors from you huh what are
you gonna give something to me the older
guy ordered a meal from me can you
deliver it to him
the older guy oh ah nice boob picture
all right what else we got here Hey
Oh sploosh okay do I have anything that
can catch the sploosh no oh this hole in
the wall that's where Oh what would that
have done who is in here before then
[Music]
okay so there's something to this right
there's something to that
okay all right okay anyway what I got so
far is I got a sweet floopy disc so
maybe I can put that in there
Oh where's the power oh come on you took
that oh you took the fish oh you mean II
you want a meal which old man which old
witch ah
oh hey old man oh lady you ain't look so
good
not now okay don't you see I'm busy
are you stupid or something meanie
you're a gosh darn meanie what did I
just get I got a number 13 oh that's the
ticket
for the order of that which I need to go
I get it okay well fine then good for me
ah here we go
hello I've got your head link okay I'm
assuming that you're not fully alive
again not that you ever were I suppose
but can I burn the wound cauterized you
know what I mean oh that guy's gone Oh
three hey that's a better number than 13
[ __ ] that I'm collecting all these
numbers hello hello
hello hello lo all right oh uh I lost
the ticket here wait did you ask I'm
looking for my number
well I got a number citrate uses 13 I
thought I have three kis to end this
pain oh well too bad for you oh no no
it's saved all right I'll be right back
okay we're back Oh I lost the ticket Oh
somebody's seen I've seen it here's your
ticket thank you my friend you're
welcome I'm such good dude and you're
cool we're cool together and you and I
are cool argh
all right but I gotta figure something
else out okay let me tell the lady that
you didn't want his meal serve the meal
he didn't wanted a old man you fine do
you pick up everything you find yeah you
want your meal tookies all squirrel you
old man I was starting to think I'd
never see it are you too stupid to bring
someone a meal Oh give it to me and get
lost I don't like you I don't like you
I'm gonna bash you over the head with a
Kruger you're not careful wait
I ordered - do I look like someone who
has teeth dude I don't know I don't know
what you look like I can't even see you
take it away and bring me what I ordered
dad dad died I'm surrounded by complete
idiots you're surrounded by people that
hate you to be perfectly honest he gave
it back he gave it back
I know he ordered chewed food but I
won't put this in my mouth I may get
sick I know what it's made from
Oh from where it's been made I'm telling
you you better not put it in your mouth
well in case you think about doing it
take the key to the bathroom with you
just go okay thank you thank you for
that thank you thank you
hello spider friend how you doing can I
get a little good look at ya no would
you like some food there you go
hope you don't get sick alright you good
you good am i good I'm still good right
okay we're good loose sploosh all right
let me just watch from the hole you good
all right fine you're good I see that
the spiders turned out to be useful okay
in what way you talking about what I'm
talking about are you talking about
something else all right
oh wait no I got it chewed food chewed
spider food I didn't know I got it
already there you go finally but where's
my drink I also ordered a drink what a
service okay she's gone but there's
water here but I just don't have a
container for it so I gotta go find a
container will trash can work with a
fleshed-out skull work can I take your
can I trade you for that you're blind
you wouldn't know right there's a drink
in there can I put a fake Wow
that seems bad seems to be toasting up a
storm there and I seem to be fine but
okay well I got a drunk you want a drink
there you go a can it's empty as your
head I try at least I try okay you try
there you'll thanks maybe you're not so
bad forgive me for my behavior I'm fed
up with this place it would be much
better if more people acted like you do
it would be much better if people didn't
act like a douche like you give kindness
to get kindness your piece poop find
them either way I got that
hello spider goodbye spider I wonder how
things would change if you like killed
all the spiders oh I didn't know I got
that well I can sew the head on that now
I think come on oh it's obviously right
there oh it's right there obviously okay
fine then anyway yeah but it makes me
wonder like what is going on hello give
me your number please there you oh I see
you're fine have you come here to ask
about your imaginary friend I have no
more work to do here I can take a look
at them all right okay
mind if I snip around your office
where's that doctor of yours all right
there you are don't you beat me here I
need your help can you bring me a needle
and thread whoa I thought I had there yo
thanks let's not waste time and get to
work
Oh God it looks as good as new now
excuse me but I have to go duty calls
okay thanks for leaving me alone in this
room with you hi how are you doing I see
our friend is much better now I hope he
has some important information for us
tell me teddy bear what were you doing
at the graveyard what were you doing
there
I was watching over my friend's parents
they lie they're dug in the ground
my friend asked me to watch over them
then the bad creature acted very badly
did some ugly things it was very rude
the creature heard us cut off our heads
hi hi I'm scared don't be scared teddy
bear being scared in this universe is
very bad you're safe here we're with you
no I'm scared I want to go home and we
won't get any information this way we
have to find a way to calm him down
he's a childlike mind find a toy or a
coloring book a watch and make sure
nothing happens to it okay thank you a
little concerned about this quote
unquote bad creature but if I turn out
the lights maybe something even worse is
gonna happen nothing in there anything
over here I get on this computer yet and
I plug it in fish something out there
stuff that in there no something else
Oh nurse why'd you lock that I may have
needed to go in there oh hello
didn't know that was out there oh also
who did that who done that who did done
Doorn that and why do i herve that what
do I need to do with that there's got to
be something else that I can fix right
I'm scared sorry I came at you with the
screwdriver didn't mean to do that
ah so we get a cab get a calm down the
dead
maybe I could do something with
[Music]
screwdriver and the wires that's gonna
really be healthy for me
maybe I could just attach this now oh
why did the music just ha ha ha ha ha
that was weird okay all right then okay
sooo there's wires there that means
there's something else that I probably
should be able to get to be able to put
in the wires plug that bad boy in plug
that bad boy in plug that bad boy in and
put this into now I thought it was gonna
be I thought it was gonna be that trick
where you put it in the trash
alright I see how this this computer is
infected I get it yeah I get it
okay load that up Oh put it in the a
floppy disk would go in the computer
that would be more that would make more
sense to fdisk
drawing this computer is infected why
are you in fook so how do I get oh hi
hello you're looking for something that
can calm the teddy bear right these
pills may help take them it doesn't hurt
to try
alrighty then well what if I give it to
the computer instead ah see I'm smart
I'm smart medicine put it in the
computer the virus has been healed I'm
smart
my coloring I knew it okay yeah one is
Blaire oh right okay two is no.3 is red
sorry don't have brown I'll take that
color then thank you I did it okay print
file
there's no [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I didn't mean it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh it's in the trash oh
oh it's in the trash oh oh would you
like this picture what a nice picture
thank you I made it myself it reminds me
of my friends drawing
logic works in that capacity but I'm
okay with that he made very nice
drawings but then stopped using colors
my friend became very sad he worried
about his parents they were old and ill
he didn't want them to die he wanted
them to stay with him forever my friend
planned to stop death to trap her he
asked all his toys for help
sadly it didn't work the last time I saw
him was at the graveyard ah I should go
back there now that I have my body again
I can return to my duties dot dot dot
can I take this picture it's very nice
yes teddy bear you can hey that's my
picture you can't speak for me
keep it oh yeah all right you didn't
slave over that art can I forever really
yes teddy bear you can keep it forever
that's gee you're so nice
thank you what about the guys made it ha
where's the credit huh okay you deserve
it you're very brave
all right interesting teddy bear said
something about the attempt to stop
death it has to have something to do
with our problems we need to find this
person only a child could imagine such
creatures this teddy bear but I don't
remember I met any child here we need to
find him right now
it's dangerous place for a lone child
anyway very few can survive here I'll
take teddy bear to the Graveyard I'll
ask him to show me which gravy watched
over maybe the child will come there you
searched in the neighborhood when you
find this kid try to find out what he
has to do with the disappearance of
death
good luck righty then thanks for giving
away my arch and telling me what to do
but either way that is the end of this
chapter we are approaching the
conclusion of this it would be amazing
if all of this was kind of imagined in
the mind of a child kind of like how
five nights at Freddy's Canon was for a
while but I don't think it is anymore it
was all imagined mind it either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]